46 seconds of too damn logos so coral
when you said you wanted an ocean view
you didn't think you were gonna get the
whole fish real estate because a lot of
other clownfish had their eyes on this
place
every single one that's interesting
since while this movie gets a ton of
actual real clownfish facts correct real
ones live in communities were only the
alpha male and female and permitted to
breed making me wonder why there are so
many damn clownfish clans in this tight
vicinity to be competing for Marlins
anemone okay sure if you say so
but all of them have their eyes open and
they're basically zygotes right now
but whatever also caviar I'd feel guilty
about eating will name this half Marlin
Junior and then this half gold
I like Nemo for all them also another
interesting moment considering that all
clownfish are hermaphrodites beginning
life is males and then changing into
females as the needs of the clan dictate
odds are one of them poor shot irony the
spirit cooter wouldn't even know about
the delicious clownfish babies if coral
hadn't darted down to protect them
motherly instinct is addictive kids
horrible predator fish knocks marlin
straight into his home where he just
happens to be extremely safe from
everything Carl
Looby kicks you in the balls at the
4-minute mark and your balls will not
recover yeah I'm only laughing because
when I went to Wikipedia to research
that earlier soon about breeding habits
of the clownfish
I read that they're hermaphrodites so if
the female of the clan is killed the
strongest male remaining becomes female
and takes her place which means Nemo is
destined to be a chick and also means I
think I just figured out the plot to
finding Dory I promise I will never let
anything happen to you again you I have
one father thinks that stripe counting
is equal to perfect health though I
should give him a break since his wife
and three hundred ninety nine children
died and left him on his own this is an
asthma but it might as well be child has
some sort of affliction that makes
survival harder cliche we go out
obsessive-compulsive disorder entire
trip to schools devoid of other sea life
and then BAM this one spot has all the
neighbors also can't you go over it this
crab gets his shell stolen but then in
the white shot the two fish bullying him
have completely changed colors and the
shit was gone either that or this school
currently has two incoming students who
shells have been stolen by dual bullies
which would be weird
even in ocean-based school
you're a clownfish you're funny right
hey tell us a joke that's fishery system
tell us a joke that's a common
misconception clownfish are no funnier
than any other fish it's also weird that
we even refer to ourselves by the human
given name of clownfish but that's
another story altogether I doubt it was
this exact one but I'm sending this
mother for being the same species or
cousin species of that thing that killed
Steve Irwin school Marty learns the
school kids are headed for the drop-off
10 fucking seconds after they leave but
arrive so much later than them at the
actual drop-off that it's basically
inconceivable you can teach a song
naming all the species to fish but that
doesn't mean they'll know which species
is which I see lots of problems with
these instructions adults arguing about
the child safety failed to pay attention
to the child cliche this is exactly how
Harry Potter lost his son and the woman
in black fish only noticed the scuba
diver when we do which is when he comes
into frame why did no one see him the
entire time Marlin the teacher and all
the students were looking in this
direction okay so I've seen this movie
before I know the ultimate moral is that
Marlin should let Nemo live his life and
not be a nagging rules-based father but
the problem is this scene that sets the
entire movie in motion sort of proves
that Marlin was right and Nemo was a
dumbass right these goggles fall off the
boat here but rest assured not only will
they be found long after this by Marlin
and Dory but they'll also end up being
some sort of a goggles ex machina kind
of thing despite them having fallen off
the boat basically in shouting distance
of where all this began east do these
fish ever know when there's something
dangerous in their immediate vicinity
Bruce turns out to be a nice shark but
still okay sure you're a nice shark but
you did everything in your power to make
the fish you brought here uncomfortable
why not tell Dory and Marlin that you're
a nice shark and have no intention of
eating them before going to your meeting
planned fish and sea creatures are
really literal is it customary for scuba
divers to write a return address on
their masks thank God for Marlins sake
right after Marlin just sat in on a
shark AAA meeting and these sharks have
done nothing to eat them he still thinks
they'll eat him which causes him to
panic and chase after Dory which then
starts a chain reaction to bruises
relapse blood cocaine
this shark has seen the shining or the
Tonight Show
but probably the shine regardless it's
ridiculous you can read I can read why
can you read your goddamn fish if fish
can read in this universe why is Marlin
so mind blown about it also sure discuss
this when a shark is chasing after you
inside jokes and just he likes bubbles
that's great but you were not on any of
these walls a second ago in the wine
shop if there's anything you need just
ask your dad or if I'm not around you
can always talk to my sister Flo Eddie
dad calls her sister Flo which if she
weren't a reflection would mean she's
Aunt Flo so there's that to think about
[Music]
you've just established they can't
understand her unless she has one or two
of her arms off the glass then
immediately ignore that rule yeah none
of the humans heard that big-ass Pelican
smacked the window none at all the
Pelican broke a picture which the
dentist takes as an excuse to talk about
his knees and directly addresses Nemo
with the ultimate reason why he doesn't
want to be in this aquarium right now
plus Nemo understands English so that's
an amazing series of fortunate events
that happened just so we can plan his
escape she wouldn't stop shaking the bag
so her parents took the cutest picture
of her with a dead fish after she
murdered it Dory and Marlin went to the
Prometheus school of running away from
things are you my conscience
Ruby sees a ton of animation time and
money by putting Dory and Marlin in the
darkest place possible anglerfish
decides to wait an insane amount of time
to eat its brain allowing Dory and
Marlin to not only admire its prey
attracting light but to allow them to
figure out that they're in danger out of
there take us out of the tank put us in
individual baggies then we'll roll
ourselves down the counter out of the
window holy everything was good to the
point of getting in the barracks but
then you're going to roll the bags how
and then the window is magically going
to be open how all drains lead to the
ocean kid and in one line of dialogue
Pixar killed thousands of real fish
owned by stupid little kids who believed
things
lu-shi is level dude okay so Dori is
lying on top of this turtle's back all
unconscious but just a second ago they
went through some sort of roller coaster
ride where Merlin had to hold on to
crush a shell so who kept Dory in place
which brings up another question why did
Marlene have to hold on to crush anyway
it's not like Marlon as a free swimming
fish was going to fall out of the Curan
or anything the only reason I can think
of is they wanted to have this cool
roller coaster ride before Marlon found
Dory again and crush wasn't really
needed anymore good thing there's a good
ol oceanic network where all sorts of
different species report the news of a
father looking for his son does this
happen every time a fish gets lost is
Marlin the only dad who ever look for a
son in the ocean blue okay so this time
the dennis here's the giant pelicans
back in the window that's convenient to
the tension of the scene if you ask me
done kids
Wow okay first of all you thought that
was kids you didn't see the fucking
Pelican how second of all you're going
to leave the window open after something
you think was prankster kids throwing
something at it when it was closed
I get that maybe the dentist is just so
dumb he doesn't look over here fine
whatever but how is the pelican speaking
English to fish without making any noise
a human can hear what is he's headed
this way right now to Sydney thanks to a
dentist who labels his scuba masks just
in case he loses it and can't afford a
new one heroes get trapped in a wheel
cliche you know I wouldn't be surprised
if he's out there in the harbor waiting
for you over right now you know trying
to figure out how the fuck it gets on
dry land to enter a dentist's office and
help with your escape okay so this whale
has a uvula when whales just don't have
uvulas which is weird because I was told
the filmmakers really went into crazy
detail on everything about all the
creatures in this movie you know beyond
the personification inaccuracies in
order to tell the story this dentist
places every bit of information these
fish could possibly need close by in
every situation the Aqua scum is
programmed to scan your tank environment
every five minutes can what does that
mean five minutes is a pretty small
increment of time but this instant scan
starting right when it's being talked
about is beyond convenient timing Dennis
gets the net taken from him but he
immediately has a plastic bag ready
which amazingly enough actually freakin
works and he does this despite simply
retrieving the net from the water have
you ever tried to catch a fish in one of
these things it's impossible Marlin and
Dory hopped down the length of the pier
instead of going at a right angle and
getting in the water in two hops
it's the Prometheus school of running
away from things for the second time in
this movie not one single seagull gets
through the sailboat pick set by Nigel
not even one guy who clearly flushed the
last fish
sides now I'll put a sneaky old fish
complete with a bag full of water into
this everyday trash can you've seen
Nigel run into this window every single
time he's flown here but now that he's
Marlon and Dorrie chauffeur the window
is wide open today somehow despite the
fact that this has never been done
before this shoots Gill to the perfect
spot Oh boobie kills another several
thousand pets with terrible terrible
science
no one's ever stuck with me for so long
before how would you know Nemo just
happens to pop out 20 yards away from
his dad after going through a water
treatment pipe together maybe we're even
looking for the same exact person and is
hilarious but two things obviously
there's no way Dory has the strength to
lift a freaking crab out of the water
but next how does she even know there
are hungry seagulls waiting above the
surface even if you did she forgets
stuff easily so I'm gonna play buzzkill
here you know like that's a surprise but
there will be enough time for father and
son to have this argument for some
reason why haven't these fish ever
thought to do this if Gil can figure
this out in an aquarium surely millions
upon millions of fish could have figured
this out over the years and spread that
knowledge
[Music]
oh okay Thomas Newman you just revealed
yourself with the soundtrack you've just
had to go back to Shawshank one more
time didn't you just one more time movie
that did all its killing in the first
five minutes thinks we're gonna fall for
this sandy plankton knew everything
wrong back in 2003 but thankfully for us
he did not start a YouTube channel to
share his thoughts with friends like
these so learning how to let his son
take risks somehow also made Marlon good
at joke telling and these assholes still
think this is funny enough even though
they heard that just to the joke five
times while he was butchering it earlier
fish Frogger know what exactly I guess
the movie is telling us they died in
those clothes bags because they couldn't
get out right
that's pretty damn dark
[Music]
that's a pretty big butt oh my god
[Applause]
the boys always go fishing with
first-timers and they don't quit
delivery or someone in
[Music]
we'll name this half Marlin jr. and then
this half you're serious yeah okay maybe
only speaks whale please commando you
hope it skews me yeah I believe you have
my paper 279 miles northwest of Dutch
Harbor the Cornelia Marie is down an
engine limping through 25-foot seas and
40-knot winds Marlin and Dory hadn't
stumbled onto the magical goggles with a
magical address written on them this
could have been a really different movie
anything ocean-based would be possible
kind of makes you think about other
ocean adventure and ocean creature
stories doesn't it or the kind you might
find on audible.com slash cinema sites
like old man in the seat or Moby Dick or
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea for Life of
Pi or yertle the turtle what do you
think I like with over 180,000 titles
available at audible the options are
basically limitless what would you do
not that kind of limitless and if you go
to audible.com slash cinemasins today
they'll give you your first audiobook
free free zero cost of any kind
guaranteed Hey I make no guarantees no
really first book is free promise
so go now to audible.com slash
cinemasins and sign up to receive your
first book free today
kaboo normally I'd be here to warn you
about an app but this time I'm here to
warn you about a book actually I'm not
even really warning you very well since
I didn't start talking until after the
image was already on screen and now I'm
already out of time